AYAYA! AYAYA! AYAYA!
Nice!
Easy-as Fack!
Easy!
MonkaW!
Nice!
eindeutig best alter wie schnell ist meine vm gerade gestartet habt ihr das
gesehen das ist das einfach durch wahnsinn na gut das ist richtig durch
geflitzt ok gibt neue updates das war gleich mal
und wahrscheinlich danach die vm rebooten dann gucken wir mal chat was hier los
habt ihr gesehen der pepo geht schon ins bett gerade pepos lieb ich muss euch
noch was anderes zeigen guckt mal hier twitter ach so das kann man es wieder
nicht aufmachen weil ach das geht mittlerweile wieder man weiß es nicht
aber es ist nicht sortiert mein gott twitter ist so beschissen geworden alter
das kann doch nicht sein es ist so schlecht einfach mittlerweile
man ich habe durchaus die ein oder andere änderung befürwortet aber
mittlerweile ist es einfach komplett useless shit man
alter twitter ich wollte nämlich was zeigen
jetzt ja guck mal ich habe heute ich habe heute ich habe heute fitness fitness
getrackert schaut mal ich habe heute fitness geht
moment response es sieht man auch nicht mehr
mein gott twitter ist so schlecht geworden das ist echt der wahnsinn
guck mal ich habe heute ich habe heute getrackt ich habe mein fitness tracker
mal gebraucht also für fürs rennen normalerweise renne ich ja nicht
normalerweise laufe ich nur relativ zügig dafür auch recht lang nicht nur
45 minuten also meine normalen so wanderrunden sind so aber so um zwei
stunden rum 130 zwei stunden heute habe ich mir gedacht ich flitze mal ein
bisschen schneller und mal gucken wie gut das funktioniert wie gesagt ich bin
überhaupt nicht geübt was das angeht und ich habe es durchgehalten 45 minuten
45 minuten 22 sekunden das waren ungefähr so 5,2 5,3 kilometer man sieht
es jetzt hier nicht genau aber man kann sich sein prinzip ausrechnen ja so und
ich muss euch sagen leute ich hätte nicht gedacht dass ich es durchhalte
ohne pause am stück ich bin es ja überhaupt nicht ja ohne pause durchgehen
fünf kilometer der gerand nicht gejoggt man sieht man ja auch hier guck mal
herzfrequenz ist eigentlich immer so um 155 am ende ab der hälfte hier ist die
hälfte gewesen hier habe ich ein bisschen angefangen gas zu geben
hier ging es hier ging es eine brücke hoch hier habe ich angefangen ein
bisschen gas zu geben zum schluss hin 5 kilometer 5,2 5,2 5,3 kilometer
man sieht es ja man sieht es ja auch hier doch das ist nicht mehr ohne training
kann man nicht sagen ich meine ich laufe seit den letzten paar jahren schon
täglich eineinhalb bis zwei stunden aber nicht aber nicht jong sondern halt
ich gehe halt so hier in der schönen gegend irgendwie mal ein bisschen
wandern so zwar mit stöckchen auch relativ zügig aber jetzt nicht irgendwie
super schweiß treiben mega anstrengend oder so aber das hat auf jeden fall
schon mal was gebracht weil wenn man es gewohnt ist eineinhalb zwei stunden
durchzulaufen relativ zügig dann kann man auch mal 45 minuten ja ja wander
sowieso so nordic walking stöcke sind das so habe ich mir gedacht ich renne
heute mal 45 minuten und ich war danach ziemlich im arsch
wobei es nicht so schlimm war wie gedacht muss ich gleich dazu sagen ich
bin mal gespannt muskelkater ich habe das ja am freitag schon mal
ausprobiert freitag waren es aber plus 3,3 kilometer
heute war es 5,3 5,3 ist komplette so eine komplette schleife hier die ich
nicht laufen kann ja viele fragen mich warum die warum die so stöcke überhaupt
dabei haben die ziehen die wirklich nur hinter sich her das ist das ist
ziemlich bescheuert ja das ist auch ziemlich useless so ich habe mir gedacht
ich poste das heute mal weil also ich habe übrigens letztens noch mal noch
mal getestet ich komme fast auf 190 noch herzfrequenz wenn ich wirklich mich
komplett die brücke hoch verausgabe so nachdem ich mal kilometer gelaufen bin
dann übelst die brücke bis zum umfall noch so knapp knapp über 190 komme ich
noch das ist für 40 jahre gar nicht mal dafür was für dich ja gar nicht mal so
übel aber dann bin ich auch wirklich komplett im arsch da kann ich ja auch
nicht weiterlaufen
so und hier bin ich halt zum schluss also der rückweg geht halt über eine
brücke und dann geht es ein stück runter und dann geht geht es halt noch
mal noch mal ein bisschen hoch und hier habe ich hat noch mal ordentlich gas
gegeben ich war nämlich auch die zweite hälfte fast eine minute schneller pro
kilometer oder 30 mit 30 sekunden bis eine minute schneller als hin hin habe
ich teilweise gehabt 9 minuten 30 9 minuten 40 pro kilometer und auf dem
rückweg also dann ab der hälfte wo ich ein bisschen gas gegeben habe habe ich
habe ich so 840 830 gehabt 220 minus alter das ist aber auch nur so pima daumen
das ist natürlich von individuum zu individuum
scheißwort alter von person zu person unterschiedlich
ich habe letztens irgendein reddit post gesehen von von irgendeinem 55 oder 60
jährigen oder so der der geschrieben hat ja ich bin gerade in den triathlon
ironman ist hans irgendwie gelaufen und ja hatte bis zu 200 oder 60 kurzzeitig
aber schon krasser krasser dude 60 freuen sich freuen sich andere wenn sie noch
die treppe runter kommen ich bin mal gespannt wie es morgen in den
oberschenkeln wird ich habe am freitag das ja schon mal ausprobiert 3,3
kilometer also quasi ein bisschen mehr als die hälfte hiervon das restliche
schleife bin ich bin ich gelaufen und dafür ein bisschen weiter also ich habe
es am freitag ja ausprobieren ich hatte sonntag samstag und sonntag extrem
muskelkater habe ich auch im stream erzählt ich hatte extrem muskelkater in den
oberschenkeln weniger in den ärmen und waden ich habe eigentlich gedacht ich
habe ich krieg es weil ich halt überhaupt nicht gewöhnt bin so von der von der
belastung hier so mit mit zu abfedern und sowas magnesium ich habe magnesium
genommen das kenne ich von früher noch magnesium brausetablette ja tatsächlich
ich habe jeden tag mittags also was ist jeden tag mit dazu als ich so übelst
muskelkater hatte und auch schon davor ich habe freitag magnesium genommen
samstag magnesium genommen jetzt ist es jetzt ist es aber wieder weg gewesen
heute vormittag und habe ich mir gedacht weiß was jetzt probierst du mal die
kleine runde aus ob die die die geht halt genau 5,3 kilometer die
probierst du die kleine runde jetzt mal aus ob die die durchgehend durchgehend
rennen kannst und es hat geklappt ich muss mich zusammenreißen ja
bereitest du dich auf einen marathon von nein ich will einfach nur wieder ein
bisschen fitter werden das alles ich meine ich mache zwar seit so zwei drei
jahren regelmäßig also täglich eineinhalb bis zwei stunden so ein
bisschen sport bisschen sport sport der eine wird sport nennen der andere nicht
ich laufe halt hier so ein bisschen durch die durch die gegend da wo es
schön ist recht zügig aber da komme ich bei weitem nicht so auf so einen auf
so einen puls dabei wenn ich da mal 100 120 130 habe bis in den berg hoch dann
ist das schon viel marathon werde ich nie schaffen aber doch doch hier waren
hier waren 29 grad aber ich bin morgens gelaufen sieht man auch hier ich bin 9
uhr 31 gelaufen bist du früher regelmäßig gejoggt
gejoggt nicht habe ich nie ich bin ich bin früher sehr viel geschwommen also
früher ist wirklich schon lange her also ich sage euch jetzt mal wie es ist
in den letzten ich bin ich bin ich werde bald 40 ja dauert noch ein bisschen aber
in dem jahr oder so ungefähr werde ich 40 sagen wir mal in den letzten 20 jahren
bin ich nicht mehr so weit am stück gerannt wie heute so und also früher bin
ich sehr viel geschwommen und ich war allgemein halt auch relativ sportlich
von fußball spielen bis fahrrad fahren und was man hat alles so gemacht hat es
ist jetzt nicht dass ich sagen würde ich habe irgendwie im verein fußball
gespielt oder ich habe hobbymäßig fahrrad gefahren also also alles
mögliche was man so geschwommen habe ich viele schwimmen fahrrad fahren ich habe
ich habe fußball gespielt was man hat früher so gemacht hat und irgendwann ist
es halt immer weniger geworden und nachdem ich jetzt die letzten zwei bis
drei jahre schon immer wieder ein bisschen bisschen was gemacht habe so
jeden tag meine runde habe ich mir gedacht vielleicht wird es jetzt mal
zeit ordentlich mal wieder ein bisschen sich anzustrengen
also ich bin also ich bin ohne scheiß das kann ich sicher sagen ich bin die
letzten 20 jahre nicht mehr so viel am stück gerannt wie hier ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob ich jemals so viel wissentlich am stück gerannt bin wo ich
noch eine ganze ecke jünger war bestimmt da sind wir ganz darum geflitzt ob es
ob es da 5,3 kilometer am stück waren weiß ich nicht aber ja jetzt zum schluss
bin ich bin ich bin ich fast umgekippt dann habe ich noch mal da ging es ein
bisschen berghoch und auf dem auf dem rückweg rückweg dann habe ich mir
gedacht komm jetzt kannst du mal gas geben bin ich in die letzten paar die
letzten paar hundert meter sieht man ja auch hier ja so sieht aus leute alles
geld weg ja garantiert wie verdient nichts behalten
das ist doch ein gb titel max es neue fitness youtuber ja und bald bald geht
es auf den mont everest moment warum gibt es warum gibt es den hier als
emot warum gibt es also hallo max nein sorry hallo hi hi wobblers okay wir
müssen hier korrekt sein ich will ja keine worte in den mund legen hi wobblers
hi at wobblers wie handhabt ihr es bei euch auf der
arbeit mit alerts aus dem monitor ich bin bei uns aktuell dran ob sie das
kenne ich zumindest so am rande das ja auch so ein atlassian tool das fand ich
gar nicht so übel ich habe nicht viel damit gemacht ich habe nur noch mit
bekommen dass das eingeführt werden sollte dass das was ich davon gesehen
habe fand ich gar nicht so übel um unseren uhr als 32 spittuhr habt ihr
auch hofbereitschaft ja haben wir allerdings bei uns ist das so gestiefe
gestiefelt bei uns ist das so gestaffelt dass man nicht wegen jedem
scheiß angerufen wird es gibt alerts für services und services haben
verschiedene quasi bereitschaftslevel und es gibt nur ein paar ganz wenige wo
die dich wirklich nachts anrufen ja es soll zwar immer abgedeckt sein dass
morgens einer da ist tagsüber einer da ist und ja abends einer erreichbar ist
aber angerufen wirst du also nachts angerufen wirst du bei uns wirklich nur
wenn wenn eines der ganz ganz kritischen systeme kaputt ist und ja
wie handhabt ihr das mit alerts ich kann dir das erzählen ich kann erzählen wie
wir das beim alten arbeitgeber gemacht haben wie wir es beim neuen arbeitgeber
gemacht haben wobei ich sagen muss beim neuen arbeitgeber bin ich bin ich
hundertprozentig sicher wie das genau geht das habe ich mir noch nicht
angeguckt ich vermute dass das über irgendwelche check mk alert regeln geht
fragt mich aber nicht genau weiß ich nicht habe ich mich noch nicht näher mit
beschäftigt ich glaube das geht über irgendwelche check mk alert regeln die
haben ja da die haben alles mögliche an monitoring unter anderem check mk und ich
glaube ich glaube über check mk gehen die geht die ruf geht geht die die die
kritischen alerts drüber und die haben da sowas das nennt sich glaube ich oder
das kommt noch von früher gab es eben so einen pager service kennt noch kennt
noch irgendjemand pager das waren so das kennt ihr aus arts sendungen früher
wo die leute dann angepiept wurden und so ja und da das gibt das heute gibt es
glaube ich nur sms und e-mails und wenn es wirklich kritisch ist nachts für den
kritischen service dann ruft dich jemand an aber ansonsten nicht so wie es beim
alten arbeitgeber war da kann ich dir das aber erzählen dort war es eine
mischung aus grafana prometheus und alert manager und ich fand das gar nicht
übel also grafana ist grafana alerts kann man
machen wenn man nicht viel hat ich muss ja sagen da bin ich in dem thema nicht
drin grafana hat mittlerweile in so neues unified alerting habe ich noch nie
ausprobiert keine ahnung wie das wie gut das mittlerweile funktioniert aber
prometheus ist relativ standard was metrik metriken einsammeln geht deswegen
finde ich prometheus gepaart mit alert manager gar nicht mal so übel wenn man
das e hat aber dass das tool kenne ich das ist ja auch ein atlassian ding das
habe ich aber nur mitgekriegt wie das eingeführt werden sollte und das gute
daran ist ja wohl dass man das relativ gut mit jira und wenn man im atlassian
ökosystem drin ist ganz gut integrieren kann und dass man eben von verschiedenen
quellen die die alerts quasi aggregieren kann was auch nicht verkehrt ist ja man
ansonsten ist immer so ein ding man muss alles über prometheus in alert manager
machen aber vieles ist halt prometheus nicht so geil
prometheus ist gut zum einsammeln von irgendwelchen metriken von was weiß ich
wie viel hat der garbage collector aufgeräumt oder meinetwegen auch noch
sowas wie wie entwickelt sich der festplattenplatz auf servern und so
dafür ist prometheus ganz gut wo prometheus was zwar was möglich mit
prometheus ist aber was nicht schön ist mit prometheus sind solche sachen wie ist
der host up oder down ist der port erreichbar http request machen gucken
ob die antwort stimmt das geht alles irgendwie mit prometheus und custom
exportern und so aber ist nicht schön da merkt man dass es nicht dafür gemacht
ist so zuki dankeschön für den sub
telekom skall werbung was ist das was ist damit das kenne ich ja ich kenne das
das ist der tool vom max zum wake on land starten vom rechner wake on land
starten das kenne ich das habe ich schon mal gesehen irgendwo 800 sterne giga
chat ja der hat halt den vorteil der macht so ein projekt nicht und stellt
an den support instant wieder ein zumindest zumindest muss man sagen hatte
hübsche sehr hübsche read me manch einer würde vielleicht sagen dass manch
einer würde vielleicht sagen dass die dass die read me ein bisschen ein
bisschen geklaut ist von ihm so ein bisschen ein bisschen ist die read me
geklaut ja aber drunter sieht es natürlich anders aus
es gibt noch neue issues also jetzt habe ich schon gesehen so was macht meine vm
ist jetzt am start mittlerweile pepo guckt fernsehsohn muss das sein
white white ist pepo happy eigentlich muss kein team akt starten
lasst uns mal den ganzen krempel starten hier bevor ich erkläre euch noch mal
kurz wo wir stehen geblieben sind ich muss mir das selbst mal
besser branche überhaupt leute ihr solltet prinzipiell immer in gitt
branchen namen nehmen die keiner versteht ja zum beispiel keckel ist ein sehr
guter branchen name dass dann verstehen wenigstens auch nur die richtigen leute
die es verstehen sollen was da abgeht er kriege korrekt ist da sind wir uns
einig so npm run müssen wir glaube machen dann müssen wir hier büschel
studio code aufmachen und einen browser ich hoffe ich krieg das das noch bei
sam wie das war jetzt lag das erst mal übelst rum beim starten ja das sieht
gut aus das sieht gut aus okay nice rider aufmachen
ist da aber das ist richtig wenn man das dann so richtig schreibt dort net
run sondern lasst uns mal kurz checken ob das der aktuelle stand war den wir
hatten ja okay passt hier sind wir stehen geblieben
geht immer noch okay also dann würde ich sagen let's go kann anfangen
ich werde jetzt noch mal kurz 55 sätze dazu sagen was eigentlich abgeht weil
wahrscheinlich waren die meisten leute das letzte mal auch nicht dabei deswegen
kann man das ja immer mal refreshen tellnet die freundin von ssh oder oder
die oma nicht die freundin die oma von ssh ist das ja daily scrum auf geht's
heute morgen muss ich auf die arbeit fahren und da haben wir den ganzen tag
daily scrum also wir haben nicht wirklich den ganzen tag daily scrum wir
haben sprint retrospektive sprint planung sprint review daily scrum sprint
retrospektive 2.0 frag mich nicht es geht wirklich morgens von morgens 9
uhr 30 bis mittags 16 uhr wird daily scrum das ist so ein tag wo ich wieder
weiß dass ich nix machen werde den ganzen tag nicht nein wird das ist
nicht mal keg alu das ist das ist das sagt sage ich auch jedem das sage ich
meinem chef schon gesagt wenn es darum geht so an dem tag ob da was gemacht
wird sagt ohne damit da kann man nichts machen an dem tag man ist permanent
mieten und das ist so gewollt das will die firma ja auch so dass man einen tag
durch mietet und insofern habe ich mir das ja nicht ausgedacht sondern das ist
vorschrift dass ich an dem tag nicht arbeite sondern miete kann ich ja nix
für nicht nicht mein nicht mein ding ja ich habe es mir wenn ich mir leute
können sicher sein wenn ich mir aussuchen dürfte würde ich eher was
machen als den ganzen tag durch mieten das ist wirklich so 39 geht es los 39
gibt es dann erst mal glaube ich sprint gibt es da sprint review gibt es als
erstes dann gibt es sprint retrospektive 1 dann gibt es wenn man glück hat
mittagessen dann gibt es sprint retrospektive 2 und dann gibt es das
nächste sprint planning sprint planning und das geht glaube ich offiziell bis
17 uhr ich habe keine ahnung ob leute so lange da bleiben aber ich habe 16 oder
10 oder so immer ab dass ich rechtzeitig zum zug kommen hat bis jetzt auch noch
keiner was gesagt ich dachte ich mache dann immer keck bei
keck bei 16 16 16 uhr fällt bei mir der hammer dann gehe ich noch runter pack
alles zusammen rucksack auf und dann geht es überhaupt bahnhof ich mache ich
komplett keck bei 16 uhr 16 uhr keck beitragen schaltest dich dann natürlich
dann im zug wieder rein ich könnte ich könnte so tun als schalte ich mich im
zug wieder rein dass ich noch ein bisschen ein bisschen remote work
abrechnen kann aber ganz so assi bin ich ja auch wieder nicht mein während der
zugfahrt hast du so viel unterbrechung da kriegst du ja gar nix mit
fängst du an also normalerweise fang ich um 7 uhr an wenn ich homeoffice mache
stehe ich auf 7 uhr rechner let's go morgen auf der arbeit fang ich
wahrscheinlich so 8 uhr 8 uhr 15 oder so an ich stehe ich stehe um ja ziemlich
ziemlich genau um 7 uhr paar minuten vor sieben so 7 uhr stehe ich auf dann
fahre ich ungefähr um 7 uhr ist es so sieben 7 uhr 35 oder so ist das glaube
ich muss ja immer immer nachgucken kann ich glaube 7 uhr 35 fahre ich mit dem
zug zum hauptbahnhof in frankfurt dann laufe ich auf die arbeit und dann bin
ich so 8 uhr 15 8 uhr 20 oder so bin ich da das geht früher früher war viel
übertriebener früher bin ich 45 aufgestanden 45 aufgestanden dass ich
um 7 auf der arbeit war oder oder teilweise war ich noch früher ich war
6 40 oder so teilweise war übelst früh aber halt einfach weil ich zu normalen
zeiten gehen wollte leute es ist komplett unverständlich für mich also
zwei sachen zwei zwei sachen es gibt sachen oder fast es gibt sachen die
verstehe ich nicht ich verstehe nicht wie ich es früher geschafft habe fünf
tage die woche zu arbeiten das nächste ist ich verstehe nicht wie ich es
geschafft habe fünf tage die woche zu arbeiten und dabei jeden tag nach
frankfurt zu fahren und was ich noch weniger verstehe ist wie es geschafft
habe fünf tage die woche zu arbeiten fünf tage die woche nach frankfurt zu
fahren und das mit der deutschen bahn und als ich noch in der in der alten
wohnung zur miete gewohnt habe teilweise sogar noch ein stück mit einem bus zu
fahren ich habe keine ahnung wie ich das fünf
tage durchgehalten habe früher ist mir komplett unverständlich ich weiß echt
nicht wie das funktioniert hat ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen ja das das kann
es wahrscheinlich echt das kann es nur sein dass man man gewöhnt sich an jeden
scheiß und und dann denkt man sich alles ja nicht so schlimm ich bin schon
abgefuckt jetzt wenn ich mal zwei tage oder drei tage nach frankfurt fahren
muss weil mich dann die bahn so aufregt ich habe den eindruck dass es früher
auch schon mega beschissen war aber die letzten jahre über noch beschissener
geworden ist mit öffentlichem nahverkehr gerade jetzt in zeiten wo er erzählt
wird so nach dem motto pharmagefälligst övp
nee wie heißt das öffentlicher öpf nicht övp övp sind die aus der aus
österreich oder das nicht die ist das nicht die partei aus österreich öpnv
ja jetzt gerade wo sie nach dem motto hier musste mal klimatechnisch gucken
und jetzt gerade jetzt ist das so beschissen jetzt wo man eigentlich die
leute dazu ja motivieren möchte das zu machen ist es halt nicht benutzbar hast
du jetzt vier tage habe ich also ich habe nicht nur vier tage ich habe die
bahn hat übrigens wisst ihr was ich gelesen habe also zwei sachen zwei
sachen habe ich gelesen als erstes die bahn hatte also dass das wall street
journal journal hat über die bahn berichtet deutsche bahn also sogar dass
sogar dass sogar das wall street journal hat über die bahn berichtet und was man
da auch zu lesen bekommt ist dass es einen traurigen negativ rekord gab wie
da muss man subscriben ich konnte das heute morgen auf dem handy
noch komplett umsonst lesen na gut und die haben da auch eine statistik
aufgegriffen dass die bahn letztes jahr einen traurigen negativ rekord hatte
nämlich dass ein drittel aller fernverkehrszüge oder aller züge ich
glaube alle aller fernverkehrszüge unpünktlich waren ein drittel das muss
man sich mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen so jetzt kommt der hit bisschen
was ich auch noch bisschen was ich auch noch letztens irgendwo gelesen habe
wisst ihr was die schweiz macht wenn deutsche bahn züge zum beispiel nach
basel oder so fahren wollen und die über 15 minuten verspätung haben
wisst ihr was die schweiz wissen was die schweizer dann an der grenze machen
die lassen den zug nicht weiterfahren da kommt man da kommt ein zug an von der
deutschen bahn mit über 15 minuten verspätung da sagen die schweizer an
der grenze darf nicht weiterfahren und dann müssen die leute umsteigen in
zwei schweizer zug der ist dann pünktlich ist kein witz
das war wirklich so hat das ding 15 mit über 15 minuten verspätung wird sich
reingelassen und dann wisse wisse darfst du umsteigen in den schweizer zug
dann ist alles gut
ja komm hey es gab mal es gab einen größeren unfall an dem man sich
erinnern kann und es gab auch durchaus größere umfälle in deutschland vielleicht
nicht vielleicht nicht so krass ich weiß nicht was die größten bahnunglücke der
letzten jahre sind aber im großen und ganzen schein dass er in der schweiz
ganz gut zu funktionieren ist eigentlich heftig wenn du überlegst
ist die schweizer bahn privatisiert also so wie ich die schweizer kenne
wahrscheinlich nicht das bestimmt die die die schweizer die staatliche schweizer
eidgenössische eidgenossenbahn oder so keine ahnung wie das ding heißt und
dann klappt das ja ich weiß ich weiß aber doch eben auch gesehen die schweizer
bundesbahn heißt das nun gut ich würde sagen wir wechseln mal kurz zu front
entstellt wird aber zeit und wie progress gemacht wieder leute massive
progress also ich zeige euch mal kurz wo wir stehen geblieben sind und zwar okay
vorher erkläre ich euch vielleicht aber ich mache den ganzen schritt hier mal zu
vorher erkläre ich euch vielleicht noch um was es überhaupt geht und zwar ganz
kurz zwei minuten weil ich will mich auch nicht immer wiederholen für die
die öfters da sind ich habe vor einer weile ein home assistant
programmiert wo man daten über sein elektroauto auslesen kann so ladestand
reifendruck und sowas was halt die apf des herstellers so hergibt das
unterstützt als hersteller fiat da weiß ich dass es funktioniert ich habe selbst
in fiat fiat jeep jeep habe ich jetzt auch schon ein paar mal in issues und so
gelesen dass das funktioniert da gibt es auch ram und dort das sind irgendwelche
dinger da stehen die amis drauf und da gibt es auch alfa romeo keine ahnung
wer das ding ob das ob das überhaupt noch einige leute fahren aber anscheinend
hersteller gibt es ja noch so das unterstützt das prinzipiell so jetzt
gibt es ein paar sachen die nicht so schön sind wo es auch ein paar beschwerden
gibt dass sie nicht so schön sind unter anderem dass man nicht mehrere
fahrzeuge unterstützt das liegt daran dass ob er bestimmt nicht mal es
unterstützt mehrere fahrzeuge aber es unterstützt nicht mehrere fahrzeuge von
unterschiedlichen herstellern also ich kann hier nämlich genau ein brand
auswählen und in usernahme password eingeben das heißt wenn ich mehrere
fiats habe auf dem gleichen account dann funktioniert es wenn ich aber ein
fiat oder ein jeep habe dann funktioniert es nicht selbst selbst mit dem gleichen
account das ist was was gefixt werden muss und es kam jetzt öfter schon die
frage ob man dieses add-on nicht auch stand alone betreiben könnte mit dem
selbst gehosten mqt server und dann braucht man ja irgendwie die
möglichkeit das zu konfigurieren also sowas hier nur halt stand alone
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir bauen ein web interface für den fiat champ
das wird relativ simpel sieht im endeffekt so aus also so sind wir
stehengeblieben das letzte mal du kannst hier einen neuen account adden so hier max
add jeep.com oder uconnect jeep was auch immer hier max add uconnect jeep.com
keine ahnung wie da die e-mail adresse ist dann gibst du dein passwort ein dann
sagt dann versuchst du dich einzuloggen so wenn das klappt dann kannst du hier
deinen pin hinterlegen den du brauchst um beispielsweise remote batterie
abzufragen und sowas zu refreshen dann kannst du sagen wie oft das refreshed
werden soll gegenüber der hersteller ab wie sagen wir alle 15 minuten oder alle
20 minuten und dann kannst du save und dann wird das ding abgefragt
sieht man ja auch hier schon updated 20 uhr 2 und jetzt wird es gerade refreshed
dann kommen die standard fiat champ fragen was ist denn das ach so nee nee
chat nein heute nicht leute außerdem ist rusting denke ich auch ich dachte
kreplang verwenden die coolen leute. Leute ich habe es euch schon gesagt
braucht keine umfragen so das wird nie passieren
so und da sind wir aktuell stehen geblieben also wir sind gerade bei
außerdem habe ich immer wieder ein bisschen bock gehabt frontend sachen zu
machen wir sind stehen geblieben dabei uns ein simples web interface für den
fiat champ zu bauen übrigens natürlich dark und light theme auch am start muss
sein ohne dark und light theme ist das ja nicht usable nein ich wusste gar
nicht dass man spenden kann jetzt über twitch was ist denn das schon wieder
warum warum kann man spenden über twitch das ist neu das kannst ja mehr oder
weniger eins zu eins glaube ich gerade in euro ausrechnen danke für deine zehn
euro ich frage mich wie viel davon jetzt bei
wir überhaupt ankommen wenn man wenn man über twitch spendet ob die sich da auch
50 prozent gönnen er wird nichts und in sick wird auch nichts rewritet wirklich
geil einfach wieder fragt man sich wie kann sowas denn durch wie kann sowas
durch die qs rutschen ja ich mache kein rewrite auch nicht in sick weder in
rast noch in sick außerdem geht es ja nur um das back end und heute machen wir
frontend damit wobei ich weiß ich weiß wenn ich sage es geht nur um das
frontend da kommen die leute an sagt ja max rast web assembly geht doch auch
sick web assembly das geht wahrscheinlich auch ja das war klar
ne oh ne ne ne leute das ist das also also ok ok nur nur theoretisch überlegt
jetzt mal angenommen ich müsste mich entscheiden zwischen einem back end also
das fiat back end neu entwickeln in rast versus sick versus c++ ich glaube auch
wenn ich c++ für die schlechteste sprache überhaupt halte versus go
dann würde ich es in go machen dann würde ich es in go machen also ich
würde ok ok wenn ich die auswahl hätte also hätte ich die auswahl c++ rast
sick oder go dann würde ich sagen auf jeden fall in go danach würde ich sagen
c++ und ja wahrscheinlich sick und als viertes rast das liegt nicht unbedingt
daran dass rast dass ich rast für eine schlechte sprache halte aber ich muss
sagen die produktivität in rast ist halt nicht so hoch wie in anderen sprachen
dafür hat es andere vorteile ja die super krassen rast kenner wenn es
wahrscheinlich wieder wenn wir da jetzt widersprechen aber für den 0 8 15 nicht
six head programmierer die sind in anderen sprachen schneller und effektiver als in
rast dafür ist es blazingly fast ja ja beim ausführen vielleicht aber nicht
beim entwickeln das ganz ehrlich das muss man mal ausprobieren ich kann es
mir nicht vorstellen rast ist einfach so so viel aus so viele sonderzeichen und
und fallstricken bestehend gut rast ist aber dafür auch die einzige
programmier sprache wo du sagen kannst hey es kompiliert es macht wahrscheinlich
wirklich halbwegs das was da steht die rast devs behaupten auch immer auf
hackernews das rast das geilste ist und machen dann so geile blog posts so why
why we choose to rewrite with rast und sowas machen die dann die verlinken dann
auf hackernews irgendwelche pro rast blog post und so wo halt die rast fanboys
sich untereinander dann da abspritzen auf rast das ist teilweise für
hackernews echt bescheuert mit den rast jüngern hat fortran überhaupt einen
eingebauten webserver wobei ich vergaß c++ hat auch kein eingebauten webserver
nach standard library rast hat auch kein eingebauten webserver nach standard
library aber go bleibt ja eigentlich nur die rewrite in go oder ja also in der
reihenfolge würde ich es wahrscheinlich rewriten wenn ich müsste aber ich muss
es nicht rewriten weil ich habe schon ein perfectly fine .net backend da muss
das muss nicht rewritet werden gut aber jetzt fangen wir mal an
leute wo sind wir stehen geblieben wir können neue accounts hinzufügen und
über den f-sharp das wäre tatsächlich noch ein ding wo ich mich wirklich gerne
mal mit beschäftigen würde mit f-sharp ja zwar nicht als rewrite von so einem
backend aber vielleicht um einzelne teile manchmal besser machen zu können
kommt ja vollständiges kompatibles .net assembly dabei raus wäre vielleicht für
manche ansätze gar nicht verkehrt was in f-sharp f-sharp ist giga pain aber
ist closure nicht das ding was aus gefühlt nur klammern besteht oder war
das eher lang was ist denn f-sharp das ist eine funktion eine funktionale
programmier sprache auf .net basis zumal man sagen muss dass sie schreibt
sehr viele f-sharp features jetzt sowas wie pattern matching und sowas er
abgreift über die letzten jahre über das heißt sie schafft wird immer f-sharp
ähnlicher aber progress leute progress muss gemacht werden progress also wo
sind wir denn stehen geblieben hier ok als erstes muss ich mir nämlich mal
angucken was passiert ich glaube das haben wir noch gar nicht abgefackelt
was passiert wenn ich versuche einen neuen account zu ändern und der server
ist nicht da ich glaube call him jd ok danke für den
sub mal kurz gucken ich habe bestimmt wieder was übersehen oder eher jd
danke für den sub habe ich nichts übersehen
ja das finde ich auch das wäre cool es gibt halt noch es gibt halt libraries
dafür aber eingebaut ins framework wäre schon deutlich besser
das klingt halt einfach mal nach folge nach funktionaler programmier sprache
da checkst du halt nix so als normaler progress dude so ich
wollte checken was passiert ok wenn der server nicht da ist dann
crash das ganze warum oder was heißt crasht ja doch geht kaputt geht kaputt
wenn das aber nicht da ist wahrscheinlich weil ich kein ordentliches
error handling habe in meiner fetch funktion ich dachte eigentlich das tut
es chat gel warum tut es das nicht ich versuche das was zu fetchen wenn das
result ok ist sage ich ok wenn nicht sage ich error aber das kackt vorher
schon ab warum kackt warum geht das nicht einfach auf error und kackt
vorher ab was was ist das ich glaube hierhin hierhin kommen wir gar nicht so
weit oder das crasht warum crash das einfach random ohne ohne das hier zu
berücksichtigen ist das irgendwie ein spezialfall oder was ist result result
loggen ich komme gar nicht bis zum loggen das kackt vorher ab guck das
kackt vorher ab catch block drumherum aber wenn ich dann catch block drumherum
brauche warum gibt es dann sowas wie ok wir fragen ist der overflow patch
error handling der chat ist über der konsole was ist das
but why chat ich schieb euch mal nutzt du eigentlich chat gpt beim programmieren
sehr selten ich benutze das manchmal für ansible files oder terraform files
ok ich werde euch mal kurz um platzieren ihr dürft jetzt mal ihr dürft jetzt mal
nach oben am bildschirmrand es ist nicht möglich zu schneller zu
machen schädige könnte mit der maus klicken aber dann dann verkack ich dann
verkack ich das alignment meines chattes das muss jetzt hier in zeitlupe hoch
geschoben werden schreibt mal einer please was im chat
dass man sieht dass wir sehen wo man es genau hingehen kopieren muss so ja sehr
gut ja passt gut sondern wenn man sich um ausblenden dass man den browser dass
man den browser ordentlich sieht genau connection infused guckt also es kommt
es kommt da unten nichts raus ach so jetzt seid ihr hier oben aber über dem
fiat champ drüber ist ja auch kacke ok wir müssen das anders machen
wobei so viel verpasst ihr da oben nicht ihr seid halt über der statusleiste
aber das ist nicht schlimm über der statusleiste sieht man da ist ja
nix komm nee außerdem ist ohne tschicko blöd
wir müssen das anders machen passt mal auf wir machen für die konsole ein
bisschen höher oder jetzt ist doch gut jetzt seht ihr was mehr brauchen wir
gerade nicht ja so ist gut also ihr seht das geht kaputt so wie macht man
ordentliches error handling patch rp error handling how to catch our patch
wort läuft dann eigentlich dieswelt kit app ja die läuft da das backend das
backend läuft nicht deswegen kackts ab aber ich frage mich ob man ich will ja
eine fehlermeldung anzeigen hier muss ich noch ein catch dahinter machen
moment ich brauche beides ich brauche hier unten den check ok hier ist eine
erklärung when a fetch request comes back bla bla bla bla error code from the
server catch of promise is not executed catch is only executed if there is a
network failure aha ok gut zu wissen das heißt wir müssen beide fälle abfangen
wir brauchen ein catch und dann dann will ich eine fehlermeldung anzeigen
wir haben doch hier oben so eine so eine message doch hier auch mal ordentlich
machen login status wir haben doch hier sowas wie eine ja so das machen wir mal
alles weg
ja es ist nicht der login fällt erzielt kein mist wir machen mal so was wie
funktion träger error toast message da kommt das hier rein und hier gibt es die
message soll weil jetzt kann ich theoretisch sagen träger error toast
error message so pass mal auf
error fetch error type type error what type type error was du meinst wenn ich
wenn ich skeleton ui rausschmeiße das ist ganz schick das ist das ist ganz
schick dass das merke ich mir mal so error punkt message weiß ich nicht was
kommt da zurück log error ich bin da nicht so fit was javascript eigentlich
was kommt da zurück einfach ein string oder ist es ein string oder nicht ok
javascript moment type of type of object top javascript jetzt weiß ich bescheid
alles klar fetch mozilla docs error catch was für ein object kommt da zurück
woher kann ich wie kann ich mir angucken type error type error und was
hat so einen type error alter javascript habt ihr nicht einfach mal hier
protokoll name constructor type error ok ich glaube chat chat ich glaube ich
einfach dass es punkt message ist ok wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich habt ihr
auch recht ihr habt recht ok das passt so und jetzt machen wir trick 17 wir
sagen einfach fragezeichen punkt ok und dann sagen wir hier unten im error fall
reger error toast login failed so und jetzt sollte das funktionieren
uns es gibt eine fehler es gibt eine fehlermeldung fürs fetchen und eine
fehlermeldung für login fällt ok so finde ich das gut damit kann ich leben
was macht punkt fragezeichen punkt fragezeichen punkt ist das gleiche wie
ich kann das mal als beispiel zeigen fragezeichen punkt ist das gleiche wie
if drumherum eigentlich ist schwachsinn ist das gleiche wie result ungleich null
und und result punkt ok das ist das ist die kurzschreibweise davon ok ok es ist
java es ist java dementsprechend auch und die feind ja also der guckt der guckt
ob result nicht null ist und wenn result nicht null ist dann greift er auf das
ok objekt zu so und das kann man so abkürzen das gibt es auch nicht so lang
das gibt erst seit als ich ein zwei javascript version dann aber konsequent
fetsch fällt nicht so viel energie auf fehler meldungen verschwenden jetzt wir
können auch einfach sagen wählt to login das ist ok so das lassen wir jetzt
so ok gefixt war das back end an dann sollte es wieder funktionieren
zack zack zack zack zack zack jawohl geht so und im fehlerfall in dem fehlerfall
login fällt ok da ist das funktioniert exzellent hätten wir das schon mal
abgehakt nächste punkt wenn wir das gefixt haben würde ich sagen ich würde
sagen wir brauchen ja eh noch ein settings menu da kümmern wir uns jetzt
mal drum aktuell haben wir gar kein settings menu man kann man kann den user
anlegen ok ja das war es dann dann steht er hier drinne aber das aber das war es
so das problem ist jetzt ich muss ja noch einige settings hinzufügen ja ich
brauche ich brauche settings für start up delay settings für location wo wo wo
wo man wohnt als betreiber damit man an richtig angezeigt bekommt ob das auto
daheim ist oder nicht also ich brauche ich brauche auf jeden fall ein settings
menu deswegen würde ich nämlich vorschlagen wir machen das folgendermaßen
wir machen diesen diesen light switch diesen theme switcher den machen wir
hier oben weg und dafür machen wir einen button hin mit einem icon für ja
nämlich help help nee settings oder settings sowas hier wir gehen mal kurz
auf tabler icons und gucken was es für schöne settings settings eigens gibt
settings gibt doch bestimmt auch jepp kog home kog server kog und settings kog
ok das gefällt mir aber alles nicht tool ist auch nicht schlecht aber settings ich
glaube wir lassen es ich glaube wir lassen es einfach so so button glas button was
das hier warum wird das so groß jetzt btn sm variant filth dann erkennt man
nämlich auch den button so machen wir machen wir hier oben settings knopf und
wenn man jetzt auf den settings knopf klickt dann kommt man auf eine extra
settings seite würde ich sagen ja das ist dann das ist dann ein bisschen
einfacher dass das zu bauen würde ich würde ich sagen weil wir brauchen eine
settings seite und dann gibt es hier oben einfach knopf und und gut ist so
machen wir das also neue route create folder nennen wir es mal konfig mode ich
weiß nicht ganz ehrlich einfach eine eigene seite ist viel simpler als
overlays wir machen eine eigene seite okay slash konfig ja gut passt dann
können wir den ganzen krempel hier rauslöschen overlays man immer immer
kopfschmerzen ja sehe ich auch so können wir den ganzen mist hier rauslöschen
und das hier im prinzip auch die karte können wir noch da lassen
wunderbar denke ich denke das passt ich finde auch dass overlays kopfschmerzen
in dem fall ist es ist es ja auch total simpel man klickt hier drauf kommt dahin
in den settings dialog und gut ist also da muss man sich da gar keine großen
gedanken mehr machen und wenn man hier wieder drauf klickt kommt man zurück oder
wenn man unten auf den save button klickt kommt man auch wieder zurück also
den den am moment vielleicht sollte ich erst noch mal hier einen keinen button
draus machen sondern ein link draus machen der auf slash konfig geht da gibt
ihr und ein button für close und dann ist wieder gut das passt so also wie
fangen wir denn am besten an ich würde sagen wir copy pasten uns gerade mal von
hier noch den header rüber um ein normal layout kann ich zumachen page die page
brauche ich nimmer ja so wirklich copy paste uns bei den header rüber und wir
wollen ja dann nicht ad account stehen haben sondern settings und wo man eine
section brauchen wir auch noch ok ja und ein futter wo dann der save button
reinkommt ja war mal als einzigen button das muss reichen zum ausprobieren
irgendwas habe ich falsch gemacht ich habe alles in header rein kopiert ich
muss das sein mit die falsche rum haben wir den light mode schon implementiert
ja haben wir was mal auf guckt mal hier zeigt ich zeigte das light switch
wobei wir ist zu viel gesagt das bringt eigentlich skeleton mit konkret hat
mal light mode ich muss euch sagen ich finde den slit den switch hier oben
neben den settings header gar nicht mal so blöd das eigentlich ganz gut an der
stelle ja man sagt ich will sieben switchen und dann geht man hier auf
setting switch einmal das sieben wobei eigentlich will ich hier unten drunter
und drunter die die ganzen sachen haben also wir brauchen auf jeden fall noch
mehr überschriften wir brauchen eine überschrift für text lg einmal haben
wir hier general settings oder global settings was ist ein besser global
general also für allgemeine settings und dann brauchen wir noch einmal was für
mqtt settings das sind ja unterschiedliche sachen
in allgemeine settings musst du das eigen im light mode nicht wechseln ehrlich
gesagt das bringt das framework bzw die skeleton 1 zu 1 mit ich will da nicht
großartig dran rum doktoren das ist okay so war ich jetzt nichts so unter unter
general gibt es dann solche sachen wie der text text input sowas hier da
brauchen wir dann zum beispiel ein text input für startup delay zum beispiel
oder so dinger halt oder oder location zum beispiel
lasst mich mal kurz checken auf dem zweiten bildschirm was war kurz meine
e-mails refreshen alarm gmx please nix alles gut
weiter ja also da gibt es da sowas wie wie hier zum beispiel label location
kurz recruiter ablehnen ja sowas gibt es dann hier unter unter allgemeinen
settings und unter mqtt gibt es dann sowas wie server und user und top pick
und was was braucht man dann noch für den mqtt server leute passwort passwort
natürlich noch passwort label das wort schieben wir das mal so leute wir müssen
mal gucken dass ich das irgendwie besser besser platziert kriege mit der konsole
docken wo docken wir die konsole kann man die oben docken ach nee man kann es
als separate window machen ich habe nicht wirklich platz für die konsole aber die
konsole war ein bisschen schmaler irgendwie hier unten hin hier müsste
eigentlich dürfte eigentlich nicht im chat sein und dann muss ich mal gucken
dass ich das dass ich mir nicht in die quere kommen ja sowas sowas in der
richtung brauchen wir dann als als settings dialog ja und hier unten gibt
es einen button für safe und es gibt einen button für cancel und der ist aber nicht
grüner cancel button der ist wie haben wir den cancel button denn hier gemacht
so ok der ist outline glaube ich einfach nur outline ja ist doch der gleiche button
cancel und safe leute was findet ihr besser safe links oder rechts ich habe ich habe schon
oft gesehen dass safe immer öfters mal links angezeigt wird weil das die natürliche stelle
ist wo die leute drauf klicken wollen und und cancel also dass links der angezeigt wird den
man öfters drückt als den anderen ja für mich ist es instinktiv auch rechts aber ich habe das
auf manchen webseiten schon umgedreht ich glaube auf github ist es beispielsweise auch umgedreht
ok das sieht schon ein bisschen hässlich aus leute lasst uns mal gucken ob die irgendwie
tabs oder sowas haben skeleton ui bei jedem release tauscht das ist eine gute idee das
wäre massive debate alter ok haben die sowas wie tabs tabs doch css tabs only
nur tables abs haben die da kann man sowas hier das ist gut guckt mal da können wir die da können
wir dann die die die unterschiedlichen options durch switchen das finde ich nice das machen
wir im port das kann man da noch dabei machen und ausschmeißen und jetzt tablet tabs brauchen
wir what an expected ach so weil typescript copypasta zeug links ist dumm ja es ist bestimmt
streitfrage ja ob der button eher links oder rechts für mich ist es auch instinktiv eher rechts den
den save button zu haben aber gut chopper ist auch am start gut dann dann probieren wir das
auch mal mit den tabs aus wie schaut das wie schaut das so aus okay sieht doch eigentlich
ganz brauchbar aus das heißt wir machen in die card jetzt hier hier den die tabs rein
und muss aber kurz gucken da ich das richtig check hier kommt der content rein das heißt
hier kommt eine section drumherum ich das jetzt richtig verstehe okay okay dann kommt
general kommt da rein und mqtt kommt da rein section hier weg in den dritten tab haben wir
noch nicht vielleicht nachher mal schauen ja das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht finde ich so
eiken brauchen wir nicht gibt kein eigen label mqtt falsch rum das hier ist general settings
und das hier ist mqtt settings ich finde das ist es ist auf jeden fall besser oder was sagt ihr
also auf jeden fall besser als alle settings die ich machen will auf eine lange seite zu
basteln da findet man dann nix mehr ist gar nicht schlecht was ein bisschen doof ist dass
sie springt oder das settings menü dass das sollte sollte vielleicht nicht sollte nicht
hin und her springen das heißt man vielleicht sollten wir das besser besser oben oben attachen
item center so glaube ich da hast du recht alfred da hast du recht ja ich dachte eigentlich
dass das moment margin top ok das gefällt mir besser daniel was gibt es ich habe letztes mal
immer nur das wort geschaut weshalb die info jetzt irgendwie die late und out of corner du
hast bei der anzeige für den refresh bin da glaube ich noch ein nicht zu viel der spinner
wird also immer angezeigt wenn nicht gefräscht wird echt sekunde ist das so tatsächlich aber
das refreshen passiert im back end wo habe ich das denn falsch in der seite für auf meiner
account card hier spinner ich habe keine extra spinner spinner component ich habe den hier das
ist richtig wenn accounts ja wenn accounts nicht refreshing ist dann soll es nicht angezeigt werden
du hast recht ja ja bei fett chat alles klar ja gut dass das hätte ich im leben nicht gefunden
ok gut gut sehr mal massive 5 wine chat wieder ist die woche zu spät ist nicht zu spät weil
der fehler ist ja immer noch da also ok chat wie würdet ihr das verstehen der save button gilt
das save button nur für den aktuellen tab oder gilt das save button für alles es ist tatsächlich
etwas missverständlich das stimmt also in github in github gilt der tab tatsächlich nur für den
wenn man safe nur für den tab also bei github hast du links das menü ja wo du dich durchklicken
kannst und da gilt das save button immer nur für die menüoption in der du gerade drinnen bist das
muss ich mir noch überlegen wie ich das am besten handhaben ja da habt ihr recht das ist aber
tatsächlich ein bisschen missverständlich aber auf der anderen seite zumindest das mit den tabs
finde ich schon mal ganz ganz nützlich ja autos du meinst autoself dann hat man das problem nicht
weiß einer was neues zu anrekordet habe ich nichts nichts mehr von gehört autoself ohne
das das das regt mich auch öfters auf beispielsweise in github manche manche settings
in autoself automatisch und für manche mussten self button drücken total wird checkt keiner
wann autoself und war nicht safe außerhalb der tabs ja dass das safe ist außerhalb der tabs
das sieht man nur nicht das selbe ist hier unten die tabs sind da drüber sieht halt immer gleich
aus aber da halten wir uns jetzt mal nicht dran auf wir machen jetzt mal ein bisschen hier
funktionen müssen da jetzt müssen als rein also juckt mqtt settings sind schon mal ganz gut so ich
glaube ich glaube die kann man mehr oder weniger so lassen ich meine was ok wir können bei den
mqtt settings können wir vielleicht noch sagen bei server könnte man noch einen placeholder angeben
und zwar sowas wie 1 und 2 1 6 8 was haben die meisten leute 1.1883 oder sowas ja super jetzt
schalte das um muss man mir hier tap set 1 machen also sowas dass die leute wissen was man da
eintragen kann leute ich habe noch eine six head id da weiß ich aber überhaupt nicht wie ich die
umsetzen soll wie wäre es bei bei settings wo man nicht genau versteht was sie machen wie zum
beispiel location oder sowas denn hilfe button wo man draufklicken kann oder ein kleines pop-up
kommt so nach dem motto ja das und das macht das das wäre das wäre doch mal richtig web 8.0
trennlinie unten ja das könnten wir machen aber dann weiß auch keiner so wirklich worauf sich
das bezieht denke ich moment macht man trennlinien so er checkt check keiner so wirklich oder
auf was sich die trennlinie jetzt bezieht aber schon mal besser aber schon mal besser als ohne
es ist ein bisschen blöd dass das so hin und her springt ehrlich gesagt ich glaube ich sollte dem
ding ich sollte ja ich sollte dem eine feste eine feste höhe geben dass man kriegt man dann halt nur
eine feste anzahl an optionen rein aber egal oder was wahrscheinlich auch geht feste breite
die feste breite skaliert eigentlich ganz gut auf dem display naja geht so also das ist meine
feste höhe angeben muss glaube ich hier rein 96 zack das reicht nicht 24 ok wie war das jetzt
noch mal bei tailwind so genau ja ein kiosk und aber das skaliert nicht richtig warum ich die
höhe angeben will dass es hier nicht so hin und her wackelt aber aber selbst wenn ich die höhe
angebe warum sind die buttons da nicht weiter unten das ist das ist skeleton ui ich will dass
die buttons unten bleiben warum macht es das nicht packt das vielleicht rum sekunde das muss
man ausprobieren ich dachte eigentlich das kann das kann diese karts geschichte von haus aus
dass die füße immer unten sind dass uns mal ein bisschen ein bisschen an der funktion arbeiten
und nicht so sehr an der optik so also was wir was wir auf jeden fall brauchen ist die server
user password topic das ist okay also optisch gefällt mir das noch nicht so gut so location
ok was was brauchen wir was brauchen wir denn bei bei den allgemeinen settings wir brauchen
location location wir brauchen überlegen wir brauchen ok ich kann einfach abgucken was wir
brauchen steht auch hier guck mal allgemeine settings location message start delay ok das
das brauchen wir alles settings das ist schwierig zu finden ja also wir brauchen location wir
brauchen ein start up delay ups start up delay nehmen wir aber das was wir letztens gebaut haben
diesen counter counter minutes ja das ist ja schon mal blödsinn counter label label ist
start delay und nicht in minutes sondern unit sind seconds das sieht doch ganz brauchbar aus
so und für das delay also ein konfigurierbares delay habe ich damals eingebaut weil wenn du
ok ich bin ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher was das problem war aber ich glaube es gab ein
problem wenn du deinen home assistant neu gestartet hast und das add-on gestartet ist
bevor home assistant komplett ready war mein home assistant startet die add-ons glaube ich erst wenn
er wenn er ready ist aber der war noch nicht richtig ready und dann hat er das erste mqtt
announcement nicht mitgekriegt und die daten wurden erst nach 15 minuten verspätung beim
zweiten refresh angezeigt deswegen habe ich da einen start up delay eingebaut und ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass das allgemein ganz praktisch ist wenn es den start up delay gibt so dann brauchen
wir noch location haben wir dann brauchen wir noch was da brauchen wir noch den text hier k oder
unknown location text da haben wir das mal weg das wird das braucht man hier wenn nämlich das
auto nicht daheim ist und man nicht feststellen kann wo es gerade ist was angezeigt werden soll
irgendwas muss ja angezeigt werden standardmäßig wird away angezeigt ist die frage vielleicht will
es ja einer umkonfigurieren machen wir mal hier let's let's unknown location gleich
away als als default als default value ja ja es gibt ja auch ein default fünf sekunden
können wir noch fest einstellen dass das default fünf sekunden ist ja start delay
mit fünf sekunden oder einer sekunde also gut leute jetzt das eine sache muss ich mal
ausprobieren guckt mal wäre das nicht cool wenn wir hier einen hilfe button hätten weil die meisten
leute wissen nicht warum man unknown location eingeben sollte wofür das da ist da könnte man
da könnte man dann zum beispiel sowas sowas drüber schreiben wie jetzt gemacht da könnte man
zum beispiel sowas drüber schreiben wie ich das text is used when the location would not be found
oder so oder wie schreibt man das determined determined we are all sitting in one boat ja
sowas könnte man da zum beispiel als hilfetext das probiere ich mal wir machen wir machen als
ein hilfetext button hin da bin ich mal gespannt ich habe nämlich gesehen dass skeleton so was
kann und zwar unter utilities pop-up gucken sowas hier will ich haben nur für den hilfetext
das wäre das wäre doch echt mal schauen wie das mal gucken wie das funktioniert okay dafür würde
ich sagen braucht das braucht der text input erst mal noch export export sowas wie den hilfetext
weil das muss ja innerhalb innerhalb davon gerendert werden es braucht sowas wie den hilfetext
und dann müssen wir gucken wie man das ganze angezeigt bekommt ich habe zu viele
dateien auf ja sowas wie help so help gibt dann das was wir hier oben geschrieben haben
und jetzt ist die frage wie kriegen wir dann ein eiken hin wie kriegt man da jetzt ein eigen
hin was eine hilfe button anzeigen wo ein overlay oder sowas hier so ein pop-up kommt
wenn man drauf klickt aha use pop-up pop-up klick ja dann probieren wir das nochmal aus wir
machen wir machen das erst mal in hässlich ja wunderbar perfekt mega hübsch und jetzt gucken
wir wie man pop-up macht sondern braucht man sowas hier ich copy paste einfach mal nur das
example um zu checken wie es funktioniert pop-up und dann muss man sowas hier machen pop-up settings
ok warum ist das alles immer in typescript standardmäßig ok jetzt ist es irgendwie
brauchen warum ist es brauchen weil pop-up ist noch die feind ok pop-up ok nice import
import was jetzt los kann auch die stadt property compute ich lecke critical information wie man das
benutzt wie benutzt man das denn hier im port pop-up habe noch gemacht ja sowas will ich haben
genau sowas hier das müssen wir nicht installieren das haben wir schon erzählt oh was ist das im
port floating ui in your applications route layout layouts aha ok import store pop-up in
your route layout und ich mache ich mache was die doku sagt und gut ist und jetzt
events klick und jetzt sollte es funktionieren und erst mal warten bis npm magic im hintergrund
gemacht hat easy funktioniert ok das tatsächlich relativ einfach so ein pop-up hinzukriegen jetzt
ist nur die frage wie kriegen wir das jetzt ordentlich allein weil so ein button da unten
drunter wo klick drauf steht den kann natürlich keiner gebrauchen ja das muss das muss schon
ordentlich also erste mal soll da nicht klick drauf stehen sondern icon schon mal was haben wir
den tabler tabler icons also help gibt es aber ich weiß nicht ob sie vielleicht auch schönere help
icons gibt was gibt es denn alles für help icons die feuerwehr kommt ist so ein fragezeichen wo
man drüber hoffert ja genau sowas will ich ja machen aber drüber hoffert bin ich bin ich sicher
weil mobile funktioniert drüber haben wir nicht fragezeichen square fragezeichen triangle help
octagon das klingt gut help octagon i also du meinst quasi info hexagon info hexagon
ja wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ist das info ist die infosache wobei hexagon
das irritiert mich das sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein würfel von wir machen was haben wir
sonst noch triangle info square oder nee komm scheiß drauf wir machen einfach round info gibt
es das nicht round circle info gibt es nicht als circle oder mal nach info suchen doch info
circle gibt es info circle icon info circle ja das ist besser so der button selbst der soll
natürlich nicht so fett sein sondern den will ich eigentlich gar nicht so großartig sehen den
button schon besser schon besser schon besser und das ganze jetzt irgendwie in an das label ja
ja das ist gar nicht so schlecht schon mal flex item center ja jetzt war das okay aber vielleicht
nicht mit grün im hintergrund das sieht abartig aus was ist ansfeld besser als an react dass ich
durchblicke und bei react nicht das ist ganz gut ja gefällt mir das eigentlich neben die seconds
packen neben den titel ja das ist ja mein ziel hier dabei guckt da so aber das gefällt mir das
gefällt mir gar nicht so wie das aussieht wir machen wir machen das mal ein bisschen anders
variant feld ist okay was warum ist es da ohne jetzt grün ach so weit hier primary noch drin
steht arrow das sieht gar nicht mal so kacke aus das ist keiner mal so stimmt so gehen wir dem
ding mal eine feste in der feste breite den fall der fälle ja das ist das ist gar nicht so schlecht
so hell so soll gucken ob der helftext richtig angezeigt wird das ich bin selbst überrascht das
sieht gar nicht mal schlecht aus ja das ist ein privates projekt dass sie guckt euch das mal das
sieht besser aus als ich mir das eigentlich vorgestellt habe oder kriegst du da drauf kriegst
den hilfetext das park auch komm mal das funktioniert sogar wenn ich irgendwo hier in
der leiste hinklickt das tatsächlich ganz praktisch das text ist jungs wenn du keine
location und be determined determined ich kann das wort nicht aussprechen ja siehst du siehst
du sehr prog aus ja das gefällt mir das gefällt mir richtig gut hat was exzellent vielleicht
sollten wir noch ok wir testen das mal weil ich sehe schon ich sehe schon den ersten back der
wo das wo das nicht so gut funktionieren wird wir kopieren das einfach mal so jetzt haben wir das
ganze nämlich zweimal und hier mal angenommen dass er ist jetzt was anderes ja sagen wir das
hat kein hilfetext und das ist einfach nur hier user oder so und da will ich ja keine wenn kein
hilfetext da ist will ich kein hilfetext anzeigen das heißt ich bräuchte sowas wie stellst du den
code auf github zur verfügung ja ist ja an ist der alte ja auch schon hier das ist ja ein home
assistant add-on web interface für den home assistant add-on wird das ich habe die blöde
vermutung dass sich das alles hier ein bisschen verschiebt wenn ich das nicht anzeige wobei wir
können es wir können es ja mal ausprobieren wenn nämlich kein hilfetext wenn kein hilfetext
gesetzt ist wenn er hilfetext leer ist ich glaube so sollten wir das machen wenn der hilfetext leer
ist dann wie funktioniert das noch mal das muss ich mir immer angucken also die if syntax von
zwölf ist wie so war doch richtig richtig gemacht also ich kann es aber nicht im button machen
achneh moin if help ich glaube ich muss es auf ein default setzen komm ich setze es auf
empty string wir haben javascript da funktioniert das auch guck jetzt haben wir hier schon mal
keinen button mehr nur hier ein button ohne hilfetext gesetzt ist das ist doch schon mal
ganz gut so und wie verhält sich das wenn es zwei elemente mit der gleichen mit dem gleichen text
gibt geht das dann auch nee fuck scheiße jetzt packt es seht ihr ich kann es ja aufmachen und
jetzt klicke ich hier drauf das ist natürlich doof das habe ich sowas in der richtung habe
ich schon vermutet weil beide elemente verwenden ja diesen gleichen verwenden die gleiche id oder
weiß ist kein ist keine wirkliche id aber ihr wisst was ich meine beide verwenden den gleichen
namen dafür dass das kommt jetzt natürlich durcheinander wenn man so klickt gibt es da
okay skeleton ui hop up duplicated oder irgendwie sowas hop up state called repeatedly when inside
each loop ja das ist sowas ähnliches gut generieren als komponenten variable und dafür
verwenden vielleicht kann man ja auch eine referenz aufs objekt setzen dass man das dass man hier
quasi die was uns das mal ausprobieren nur ob es theoretisch funktionieren würde id hecke ja dann
dürfen wir hier wahrscheinlich nix setzen oder so und dann ob das jetzt funktioniert dachte man
kann das na gut ok pop-up klick ist natürlich schon mal blöd das soll heißen help ok was was
schreiben die hier denn dazu mehr text please hier ach guck mal hier machen sie das auch post
id post id habe ich ja nicht chat ihr habt wieder 5 hat time recht ihr habt recht ich glaube so
machen wir das ich glaube so machen wir das wir gehen das aber aber ein bisschen eklig ist es
schon oder wir können die id generieren und und das dann da reinsetzen jetzt ist natürlich bloß die
preisfrage browser generate eu id 2018 ist es gut was generell random id in javascript math random
ne ne damit fange ich nicht an da weigere ich mich da muss es was eingebautes geben da
muss es etwas eingebautes geben kann doch nicht sein das ist eklig api call zu eu id generator
nein das ist das muss das muss besser gehen was das crypto random eu id ok lasst mich raten safari
unterstützt das nicht can i use moment safari kann das was ist da los an dem moment safari
technology preview ios safari wo ist mein safari kann das einfach das hätte ich nicht gedacht dass
safari das einfach so kann und warum ist das nur available hatte tps ok hatte tps oder local
host wahrscheinlich ok also wie von start gleich jetzt einfach crypto eu id easy easy kann man
dazu sagen das ist quasi und was generator der da jetzt genau tatsächlich das funst ok das ist
gut so jetzt muss ich mal überlegen wie kriegen wir dann das hier reingebaut so und darin jetzt
ein template string oder hat es denn nicht auch hier so gemacht guck mal man kann es auch inline
schreiben hier noch besser schreibe ich das doch mal inline moment data pop-up kann ich einfach so
machen also in der das war ok help minus eu id ok und jetzt und hier hier taget taget ist help
minus eu id ok und funst das jetzt und es packt nicht rum ok das das ist vielleicht nicht die
allerschönste lösung aber die funktioniert was brauchst du die eu id jetzt naja dass dass die
dass die pop-up id ist einzigartig sind weil ansonsten kommt das ich in die quere mit den
pop-ups wenn die die wenn die den gleichen namen haben guck wenn die beide help heißen wenn die
beide help heißen dann du siehst er packt rum wenn ich hier dazwischen versuche zu switchen
wie gefällt es welt es ist es mittlerweile mein lieblings frontend framework ich mag das
ist richtig nice so also ich muss sagen dass mit dem hilfe button finde ich mega das lassen
wir so das kommt weg weil das brauche so wenn jetzt einer keine ahnung hat was an laut an
location text ist klickt er hier drauf und dann ist gut da kriegt er das angezeigt das gut so
user user ist bei der way nicht nicht away das gefällt mir das ist nice und ohne typescript
warum kannst ganz normal typescript verwenden kannst auch typescript ohne probleme verwenden
willst so also wir haben unsere settings seite mit tabs gut das ist ich finde das sieht optisch
gar nicht mal so übel aus kannst hier auswählen kannst du hast du gerne hilfe hast du keine hilfe
texte dabei das schon cool das war nice das gefällt mir so dass nein nein nein nein nein
nein das haben die ein bisschen blöd die pressemeldung oder was das war aber ein bisschen
das stimmt überhaupt nicht das welt unterstützt typescript wie eh und je das einzige was die
gemacht haben ist intern im framework verwenden sie kein typescript mehr das heißt aber nicht
die offiziellen examples gibt es sogar sogar glaube ich nur mit typescript also die wollen
dass du typescript verwendest die wollen bloß intern kein typescript verwenden weil weil und
das ergibt aus welt sicht auch sinn warum die intern intern kein typescript verwenden also
das welt verwendet intern bei innerhalb vom framework verwenden sie hauptsächlich wo habe
ich die denn ja die verwenden so type annotations intern im framework es gibt aber für alles
generierte typescript typen und der grund warum es welt selbst intern kein typescript mehr verwendet
ist weil es welt ja kein klassisches reines javascript framework ist wurde dann erst mal
drei mb javascript runterladen muss dass das ausführen kannst sondern es welt entfernt sich
ja zum größten teil beim bildvorgang wieder was zwar immer noch ein paar kleinigkeiten aber im
prinzip ist es nicht so wie bei react oder view wurde das eigentliche framework noch runterladen
muss sondern es welt ist an sich selbstcontent javascript anwendung ohne dass du zusätzlich
framework unter also das welt kompiliert sich quasi selbst raus im bildvorgang dementsprechend
die seiten mit welt auch relativ klein und da hatten sie probleme mit ihrem custom javascript
compiler typescript zu unterstützen da hatten sie immer so doppel doppeldeutigkeiten drinne
und deswegen haben sie gesagt sie verwenden intern in das weltentwicklung kein typescript
mehr im framework innen drinne aber supported wird typescript ohne problem und die offiziellen
examples gibt es glaube ich sogar auch mittlerweile nur noch mit typescript ist das nicht bei angela
auch so was genau also ist das javascript bisschen schon ja also angela ist also ein
business enterprise ding da hast du tausend sachen eingebaut dass es sich wieder entfernt
nein nein das ist nicht so das ist eigentlich nur das welt so die anderen musste erst mal
komplette framework runtime runterladen und angela kann ja gefühlt alles aber ich finde
angela ist auch mit abstand das hässlichste ich mag das überhaupt nicht ich habe dafür ich habe
davor hauptsächlich future erst benutzt aber seitdem ich mich ein bisschen mit zwölf angefreundet habe
finde ich das extrem nice also richtig okay also dann müssen wir uns jetzt mal wirklich
kurz überlegen was man was muss was brauchen wir da alles also wir brauchen ein startup delay
das ist okay so wir brauchen ein oh ja wisst ihr was wir brauchen da werden sich die amis
freuen wir brauchen selektor zwischen imperial und matrix system ich hatte schon das problem
weil die fiat api die gibt sache nur in kilometer aus oder würde man sich eigentlich denken das ist
kein problem aber es gibt leute die wollen die sachen in miles angezeigt haben und aktuell hat
aktuell gibt es in dem addon dieses setting hier force convert kilometer zu miles ich würde sagen
das sollten wir auch weiterhin supporten sonst drehen die amis durch da machen wir mal so einen
so einen select oder irgendwie sowas hier select option aber hier war metric wie geht das metric
und imperial und wir brauchen noch ups und wir brauchen noch eins wir brauchen noch ein
autoselect sieht so kacke aus was das okay schon ein bisschen besser aber auch aber auch nicht aber
auch noch nicht hübsch hübsch hübsch ist was anderes okay was das mal kurz bei skeleton
ui gucken talent forms option select nach so glas selekt okay eigentlich glas selekt
aber sieht so abartig ekelig aus ach so okay warum ist das grün das ist verpackt sieht kacke
aus okay da habe ich jetzt keinen bock drauf mich mit css gedöns auseinanderzusetzen das
ist mir zu blöd okay wir brauchen start up dann brauchen wir noch wir brauchen noch normale
location home location when the car is close to this location it is at home ich hoffe ich
hoffe man versteht was ich meine englisch pros sagt mir wie ich das besser schreiben kann also
im prinzip ich kann es euch auf deutsch sagen was damit gemeint ist wenn man den standort vom
auto ausliest und es ist halt in der nähe von der hier gesetzten location dann gibt es als status
home bind ist schon mal blödsinn hier müsste man jetzt halt hier müsste man jetzt halt die home
location eintragen in längen und breiten grad das kann es doch keinem zumuten oder längen und
grad okay ich weiß jetzt ich weiß jetzt wird es vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben weil man
einen button machen mit mit lief wird wo man wo man auf eine map klicken kann wo man wohnt das
muss aber ausbilden okay vielleicht also das ist vielleicht dass es overkill vielleicht ist es
overkill und vielleicht schmeiße ich es auch wieder raus weil es zu kompliziert wird aber wir
können also das ist das erste was mir einfällt bei maps lief wird die frage ist ist lief wird
überhaupt noch das was man was man so benutzt was ist aktuell angesagt lief wird versus ach
komm scheiß drauf wir benutzen lief wird er weiß na map box braucht man api key und das
kommerz kommerziell zum größten teil tutorial die flit quick starter guide das machen wir jetzt
wir machen das mit lief das brauchen wir nicht kann man die flit npm install npm npm how to
install install npm box install npm wie gibt es kein npm doch gibt es doch gleich ort liegt wir
wissen doch ich wohne mitten im main laut meiner browser location das wird es wieder anzeigen ok
npm install lief wird es go lief blitz tutorials lief wird quick starter guide im port ok wie
funsten das jetzt richtig ich brauche eine karte ok home location ist dann ist dann ok
home location es gibt hier kommt eine karte drunter diff da muss man auch einen diff
ist das exempel ja def id gleich map gut dann soll man dem ganzen eine größe geben das können wir
auch hier machen sagen wir mal einfach reite ganze seite und höhe keine ahnung 690 oder so gut hier
soll die karte dann hin das doch schon mal ganz gut aber schon mal platz für die map war map gleich
l punkt map ja gut aber ich muss es doch erst mal importieren denn es war klar dass es nicht
funktioniert wie importiere ich das wie importiere ich l l wait a minute das brauche ich wahrscheinlich
im port lief wird ist kann ich einfach sagen im port lief wird so ok npm macht im hintergrund
irgendeine magic das spricht schon mal dafür dass es das ist dass irgendwas funktioniert davon guckt
euch das mal ja meine güte ist ja gut jetzt ja was kriegt kriegt ich mein not found muss ich
da jetzt sowas wie map importieren ok jetzt muss ich l wahrscheinlich wegmachen an dem moment jetzt
gibt es ja map doppelt kann man kann man nicht einfach sowas hier machen l from lief wird oder
so jetzt eigentlich l punkt map map container not found ah ja das ist ja noch gar nicht geladen zu
dem zeitpunkt ja das stimmt wohl ja das ist noch gar nicht geladen das führen wir aus und klick
oder sowas würde ich sagen weil das wird ja auch unloaded das will ich ok ich habe eine idee wie wir
das machen und zwar wir machen was welt reactive magic if ups ja ebset gleich gleich 1 oder wo
sind wir auf general auf 0 dann machen wir das was ok ja was kriegt was willst du mir sagen ok
es muss daran liegen not implemented an die fein was willst du alter ok so funktioniert das schon
mal nicht wir machen das jetzt mal easy mode set timeout 500 millisekunden und jetzt nice es
funktioniert das ist nicht weiß hat dass es nicht dabei ist dass das los da muss noch was besseres
einfallen aber immerhin der lehnt schon mal der lehnt schon mal was ok lief mit exampel teile ja
was hier los aber warum sieht es so kacke aus was das da ist da ist jetzt fast grundlegend
liegt bestimmt an der vm nein das liegt nicht an der vm ok lief mit ränder ero lief mit not
rendering properly ja ja genau sieht es aus im port lief mit dist lief mit css moment moment man
kann sekunde das funktioniert nice moment sekunde sekunde man kann in einem javascript tag css
importieren kann man denn wenigstens in css auch css importieren das ist bundler magic ja guck mal
kann ich denn jetzt auch ok ok ich lasse es hier mal weg könnte ich das auch hier irgendwo habe ich
denn überhaupt mein css mein css file app wo ist es denn das will ich wahrscheinlich nicht haben
wie würde man ok jetzt mal blöd gehört wie würde ich denn in wie würde ich denn in import gibt es
da auch sowas wie importiert man denn innerhalb von css css import im port im port und dann einfach
so ja chat was ist besser css im css importieren oder css im javascript wisst ihr was ganz ehrlich
wir machen css im javascript warum warum nicht da steht ja alles schön untereinander vollkommen in
ordnung ja ja das ist ok ja war so ok ich würde vorschlagen anstatt es irgendwie auf city of
london zu setzen sollten war die location auslesen von dem browser gibt es eigentlich verschiedene
themes ja du kannst hier den das teil set auswählen auf dem street maps teils da gibt es und die
unterschiedlichsten unterschiedlichsten sachen ich weiß aber nicht wo man sich die angucken
kann oder es im bright dark matter 3d gibt es unterschiedlichste sachen aber ich glaube wir
lassen das erst mal das ist das ist sowohl ich finde das ist sowohl dark als als auch
light theme tauglich die map hier oder finde schon so jetzt ist natürlich die große preisfrage
erstens wie kriege ich im browser raus wo ich bin zweitens wie kriege ich raus auf welche location
ich hier gerade drücke ok das erste leaflet ladlon klick so on click map mouse event to lad link
das erste wäre möglich nicht so schlau das macht nix man sieht einfach nur dass ich in hanau in
in mein in mein an in hanau also in mein neben hanau wohne laut meiner location im browser das
könnt ihr ruhig wissen dass ich in mein neben hanau wohne kann man auch ok das ist ja eigentlich
nicht verkehrt blick mac ios dafür den problems ab so kann ich sagen map on click easy das ja
einfach jetzt haben wir die location rausgekriegt wo man wohnt kann man einfach hier mit dem klicke
auf die map easy ok das ist gut das ist das ist ja mega einfach cool das ging viel einfacher als
gedacht habe und wie kriege ich jetzt meine location browser geolock location browser geolocation api
geolocation get current position gespannt ok lock geolocation get
geolocation api is accessed via a call to navigator geolocation navigator geolocation
ok nice get current position success callback kann man das nicht kann man das nicht erwarten
vielleicht ja ist ne man muss es mit komischen callbacks machen ok hack javascript ok wie geht
das jetzt success callback also sowas wie hier pos und dann so oder wie wir sollen das checken
location was neue location allow geolocation timestamp da wohne ich hier gucken wir mal wo
das ist gucken wir mal wo das ist wo ich angeblich wohne und zwar ach nee wie setze ich das denn
jetzt wie setze ich das denn jetzt ein callback muss ich den ganzen müll jetzt in den callback
packen hier eigentlich ok koorts es heißt ich brauche position koorts das brauche ich
und ich wohne moment gucken wir mal wie genau das ist ich wohne im main ja was ist denn
schöner zoom ja ich wo ich wohne ok heute wohne ich ein stückchen neben dem main angeblich heute
wohne ich angeblich hier so irgendwo im main ok hier marine hier wohne ich guck mal marine
kameraschaft hanau alles klar u-boot haus liegt ja schaut jeder ist da ist meine private insel
hier irgendwo hier guck das was ist das die fall zum level überhaupt 13 das ist eigentlich ganz
gut das war easy mit der map und ich klicke hier drauf und schon habe ich die schon habe ich
längen grad breiten grad und sowas das ist das war jetzt richtig einfach dass er nicht gedacht
dass das so simpel ist ehrlich gesagt ihr also das war jetzt es war mir fast schon zu einfach
erstmal auf kann man denn die map kann man kann man die rounded machen guck mal die map ist sogar
rounded jetzt sehr schick sehr sehr schick das gefällt mir setzt was einen marker ok gute
idee chat wie setzt man den marker bestimmt map marker oder sowas nee
lief wird da gab es doch da gab es doch eben ein beispiel marker marker circle marker hier
to map sie marker to map link warum warum nennen wir das nicht einfach location oder
oben heißt es position nenne ich das auch so was das ist auch wieder unterschiedlich heißt
jetzt linke heißt top ist not defined mokas sagt da haben wir einen marker easy easy markierung
stellt ein bisschen viele marker oder und und und die unter pointer ist ist halt input adresse
suchen das nicht möglich da brauche ich da brauche ich irgendeine irgendeine datenbank
für adresse search das das geht nicht so ohne weiteres der alte marker sollte verschwinden ja
das wäre doch durchaus sehr sinnvoll ja da muss man wahrscheinlich sowas machen hier wie map ok
lief let's move marker all markers how to clear map of markers perfekt clear layers
nicht markers map jetzt kaputt jetzt kaputt is not a function if you want to remove all the
current layers markers in your group can use the clear layers what what kannst du nicht die position
vom alten marker überschreiben ja wahrscheinlich dann machen wir mal einen marker hier an 0.0
das ist eine gute idee marker was hatten der so alles zu bieten den kann man nicht
überschreiben den kann man nur einmalig anlegen ach hier ist doch easy fast habe
ich vergessen wie das shit hieß copy paste man easy das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so schwer
gewesen das ist das ganze eigentlich in einem timeout weil ansonsten das element nicht geladen
ist doch doch on mount reicht wahrscheinlich auch aus aber ich will das wahrscheinlich gar
nicht so direkt reinladen weiß ich noch nicht genau das mit dem timeout war erstmal dass es
überhaupt funktioniert jetzt direkt ok nice das funktioniert vielleicht sollten wir jetzt
noch mal den ich bin dem muss nämlich gleich ins bett vielleicht sollten wir jetzt noch mal
vorher den hier den pointer umstellen auf sowas hier guckt mal viel besser geht auch so nach
pointer aus so und dann brauchen wir hier eine variablen für die location position home position
und dann setzen wir das hier drinnen auf position und dann zeige ich das mal an mal gucken ob das
im prinzip funktioniert home position und die feind ja ja sonst ist ja mega das war viel
einfacher als gedacht ok zu zu lul wer sollen das lesen können was laune sagt alles klar
zu lul time aber es funktioniert oh leute hier unten konfirm die flair das ice wall ist da shit
liefert hat es konfirmt wozu dient der marker der marker wird dazu dienen dass man einrichten kann
wo man wohnt dass das richtig erkennt ob das auto zu hause zu hause ist oder nicht aber wenn du hier
wohnst da oben in sibirien irgendwo dann kannst du sagen hier wohne ich und hier oben leute ist
auch irgendwo auch diese stelle wo der komet explodiert ist und den wald vernichtet hat
kennt ihr dieses bild wo irgendwie zig kilometer wald einfach umgekippt sind durch den durch den
kometen durch diese kometen explosion macht ihr programmieren selbst abends um zehn nach der
arbeit auch spaß ja warum nicht ich bin ja kein hauptberuflicher softwareentwickler vielleicht
würde ich mir dann auch keinen bock mehr machen so guck also mal genommen du wohnst jetzt hier
in da genau da hier da beim roten kreuz und du packst mit deinem auto dort dann erkennt das er
das auto ist daheim wenn es innerhalb von einem gewissen radius ist okay mir reicht es heute genug
fein verteilen haben wir doch wieder ordentlich progress gemacht und das muss ich mir echt mal
angucken das finde ich wirklich ganz nice max wenn ich das nächste mal wieder flame über skeleton
ui und irgendwelche ui sachen rausschmeißen will dann werde ich das mal verwenden emoji support
das ist ja schon mal enorm park was machst du hauptberuflich guck mal bei mir auf github nicht
auf github was laber ich von scheiß guck mal bei mir auf youtube da habe ich zig videos zu dem
thema gemacht wie komme ich auf github auf youtube guckt du kannst von mir auf youtube gucken wenn
ihr hier so durchs kreuz kriegt findest du 30.000 video zu was was mache ich denn so auf der arbeit
letzte arbeit sagen sie muss mal gucken gibt es gibt es einige videos zur neuen arbeit habe ich
tatsächlich noch kein video gemacht wieso muss das ändern das wenn home assistant wenn das wenn
das an als home assistant verwendet wird dann zieht es sich das von home assistant da musst du
nichts einstellen aber es gibt ja leute die wollen das auch stand alone verwenden dann brauchst du
das mir gefällt habe ich schon öfters erzählt im stream mir gefällt es gibt so ein paar sachen
die mich nerven das ist nicht exklusiv das habe ich schon total oft erzählt gibt es ein paar
sachen die mich nerven ja zum beispiel dass die extrem bürokratisch sind das hat ja alles seine
vor und nachteile also bei der alten arbeit konnte es hier zum beispiel passieren dass irgendeiner
morgens reingekommen ist um um halb neun hat gemeint hier heute ganz wichtiger service
herzensangelegenheit des vorstandes lass uns mal was machen das gibt es auf der neuen arbeit nicht
wenn da nicht mit drei durch drei durchschlägen das deployment beantragt wurde dann ist da nix hat
seine vornachteile das ist nervig und also wie gesagt so dieses dieses überbürokratische und
teilweise übertreiben sie es auch komplett mit irgendwelchen regelungen und vorschriften also
ich weiß nicht also da übertreiben sie es und vor allem im security sektor sind sie gar nicht
wie soll man sagen so so richtig krass secure sie sie machen halt so dinger wie es ist ja auf
der einen seite sagen sie alle sollen windows only benutzen und dann kleistern sie windows
so zu dass das kaum verwenden kannst die hätten 90 prozent der probleme gar nicht wenn sie die
leute einfach linux benutzen lassen würden die wollen naja linux architekt heißt die position
nicht aber sowas sowas in der richtung ich mache ich bin senior linux engineer nennen sich das
aber letztendlich ich mache ähnliche sachen wie das weil ich auf der alten arbeit gemacht habe nur
deutlich mehr noch deutlich mehr cloud geduld aktuell ich bin ich bin bei einem projekt dabei
und wir machen also ich war aktuell 90 prozent google cloud und dort ist es hauptsächlich
kubernetes und halt alles was in google cloud damit so zusammenhängt von secret management
die zertifikate cloud sql datenbank und sowas das mache ich in der tat eher weniger zur zeit ja
das weiß ich nicht ob ich das erzählen kann aber ich kann dir sagen weder noch das ist auch so was
was mich beim neuen arbeitgeber ein bisschen nervt dass die für vieles so eigen gestrickte
dinger haben oder sagen wir mal nicht nicht nicht unbedingt rein selbst gestrickte sachen sondern
auch suboptimal eingekaufte sachen wo dann irgendjemand gedacht wurde wobei ein guter
marketing typ da war und es denen verkauft hatten jetzt meinen sie man muss das benutzen
ja schon mal ein tweet gesehen wo sie einem einfach das quota wir geben da so viel geld aus
wir haben sogar also du merkst man merkt an einer sache ob man viel geld bei einem cloud anbieter
ausgibt oder nicht wenn man einen kontakt hat den man in teams anschreiben kann und wenn man
sogar ab und zu meetings und calls hat mit google leuten die für google für die google cloud
plattform arbeiten und man dort ein bisschen meckern kann dann weißt du okay du gibst so
viel geld aus dass google sogar die irgendein typ hinsetzt als ansprechpartner also dann weißt du
da ist da ist schon einiges was da reingebuttert wird weißt du eigentlich wie hoch dein eq ist ja
weiß ich zumindest habe ich mal vor uhrzeiten habe ich mal einen test gemacht das schon richtig
lange her da war ich glaube ich 15 oder 16 oder so weiß ich ja 15 16 war psychologe habe ich
damals den test gemacht richtig lange gedauert glaub glaub fast eineinhalb stunden oder so
ewig lang was kam raus messe feuer q kam raus es kam raus dass sich weder sonderlich 3 head bin
noch ultra feil fährt ja das kam raus ich glaube 131 war es 131 aber das hat insofern
wenig zu sagen weil ich auch gar keine ahnung habe welche skala das genau ist und so ich
muss mal meine mutter fragen die hat das bestimmt noch irgendwo die hebt hier alles auf endlich
jetzt ist es endlich bestätigt leute hiq stream die subs auf twitch haben quasi retroaktiv damals
mein intelligenztest schon beeinflusst so ist es jetzt wissen was endlich bestätigt leute hiq
stream big brain teil es kommt übrigens also das kann man pauschal nicht sagen es kommt auf die
auf die diese bewertungsskala an es gibt es gibt ich kriege das nicht mehr richtig es gibt irgendwie
drei oder vier verschiedene so test bewährt unterschiedliche test und bewertung und es
schwankt ja beim einen ist das gut beim anderen ist es nur durch das ich kann es keine ahnung
ich glaube schon dass es nicht schlecht war dass da schon sagen wir mal ganz brauchbar ist aber in
welcher skala ich habe keine ahnung wieso warst du beim psychologen nur wegen dem test oder magst
okay also nee ich war nicht nur wegen dem tester meine mutter hat mich damals zum psychologen
geschleppt weil ich etwas ja so meine probleme hatte er somit so mit 15 aber viele leute sind
mit 15 nicht mal ganz dicht 15 15 16 das war so das wo ich dann mit der schule auch fertig war
in dem in dem dreh und wo ich dann nur 24 sieben mmo kreisel krank gemacht moment nicht dass ich
das misserzähle 1984 plus 15 ja doch da war ich ungefähr war ich ungefähr mit ja ja doch doch
genau das ist das da war ich mit der schule fertig und habe nur nur am pc gehockt und es war dann
komplett vorbei also ich war 2000 oder so war ich mit der schule fertig irgendwann in dem dreh
so und in der zeit habe ich halt wirklich also ich habe ich habe meinen realschulabschluss ganz
knapp geschafft weil ich halt nur vom pc gehockt haben und sachen gespielt habe oder oder gebastelt
habe oder hauptsächlich sagen gespielt habe und nach der schule dann da war wurde das noch schlimmer
dann habe ich einfach gar nichts gemacht da habe ich den ganzen tag habe ich euch ja schon ein paar
mal erzählt da habe ich einfach da habe ich einfach den ganzen tag daheim gehockt und als
dann als dann da jetzt auf camera rausgekommen ist ende 2001 ich glaube das ist in europa erst
ein paar ein paar monate später rausgekommen habe ich mmo kreisel krank gemacht von morgens bis abends
wann war denn europa release ja weiß man nicht ein halbes jahr später oder so ich habe nur kreisel
krank gemacht so und irgendwann hat meine mutter dann gesagt das geht so nicht weiter du musst
eine ausbildung machen und kannst den ganzen tag nur vom pc sitzen und sowas ihr kennt das ja
vielleicht von euch auch ähnlich vielleicht ähnlich ja und ich hatte halt keinen bock ich wollte keine
ausbildung machen ich wollte ich wollte einfach in ruhe gelassen werden und 24 sieben mmo kreisel
machen und ich habe mich damals ein paar mal beworben aber aber halt auch halt nicht wie soll
ich sagen ist nicht mit der intention genommen zu werden dementsprechend waren meine bewerbung
halt auch total lieblos und dumm geschrieben ja ich wollte ich wollte ja gar nicht genommen werden
weil wenn ich irgendwo eine ausbildung bekommen hätte ich aufhören müssen mit mmo kreisel
krank eigentlich hat überhaupt keine bock zu arbeiten ich wollte daheim vom pc sitzen
naja und ich habe ja dann ich habe ja dann auch irgendwann noch eine andere ausbildung angefangen
das habe ich auch schon erzählt ich habe mal bwl zeug gelernt ich habe mal büro kaufmann gelernt
aber habe ich nie fertig gemacht habe ich angefangen und habe dann auch gesagt nee kein
bock mehr ich mache wieder mmo kreisel krank ich habe das nicht lange gemacht wie gesagt
ich habe schon auf dem stream erzählt ich glaube das einzige was ich was ich mir gemerkt habe von
der ganzen von der ganzen ausbildung dort ist dass man linear oder degressiv abschreiben kann
um das eine geht angeblich nicht mehr habe ich gehört und die buchhalter nase kann ich noch
ansonsten kann ich nichts mehr ja nicht der reiter auf der brust so und nachdem ich mich halt so oft
erworben haben es hat nicht geklappt und da hat mich meine mutter erst zum arbeitsamt geschleppt
und hat sie mich dazu gebracht immer weiter bewerbung zu schreiben ich habe die halt schlecht
geschrieben ich habe mich damals auch tatsächlich für it ausbildung schon beworben so 2002 oder so
oder 2009 90 2000 2001 rum irgendwie für it ausbildung beworben damals gab es noch kein
fachinformatiker system integration die gibt es glaube ich erst seit 2004 oder sowas damals gab
es noch it system elektroniker und solche geschichten aber damals war es so es gab viel
viel mehr aus also leute die die ausbildung stellen haben wollen als leute die also als
betriebe die das anbieten habe ich nichts gefunden ja dann hat mich meine mutter zum
arbeitsamt geschleppt und irgendwann irgendwann hat sie mich auch mal zum psychologe geschleppt
ich vermute mal eine der hintergründe war oder warum der warum der psychologe also psychologe
intelligenz das war wahrscheinlich zwei sachen erstens weil sie im geld bringt und wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich gucken wollten ist der typ nicht vielleicht einfach nur zu dumm also nehmen die den
nicht weil er einfach nur zu dumm ist das kann durchaus ein valid grund gewesen sein warum warum
ich das machen sollte also sprich guckt überlegt euch mal über muss man sich mal reinversetzen ja
da kommt da kommt eine mutter und meint hier mein sohn verkackts voll die ganze zeit mit
seinen bewerbungen sitzen ganz nach nur vom rechner und spielt und bewerbung gibt es immer nur
absagen und wenn er irgendwo hingeht dann wird das nix und da hat der psychologe wahrscheinlich
gesagt hier um mutter max vielleicht ist einfach nur zu dumm und daraufhin muss ich so ein ding
machen ich kann mich da gar nicht mehr richtig daran erinnern man musste man musste also an
einer sache kann ich das kann ich mich noch erinnern dass es war auf jeden fall nicht so
dass man den ganzen test alleine irgendwo irgendwo hocken musste ja man hat man hat
sachen gezeigt bekommen der hat einen sachen gefragt man musste aber auch ich kann mich
dann noch ganz schlecht daran erinnern man musste aber auch manche sachen manche sachen erkennen so
nach dem motto so führen sie diesen satz fort und solche geschichten war das oder poggers verhält
sich zu pog champ wie pega zu irgendwas so so dinger war da war da war da drinnen und
er ist schon ist schon ein bisschen her ja okay so sah das aus und ich ich habe tatsächlich
damals mir da mühe gegeben weil ich weiß gar nicht mehr warum ich habe eigentlich nur 24 7
gemacht aber ich glaube ich habe mir gedacht gedacht ich muss da mitmachen dass meine mutter
beruhigt ist oder so ich weiß es nicht ich dachte okay wenn ich mich wenn ich mich da jetzt recht
rein versetze ich gehe davon aus ich dachte mir damals wenn ich da ordentlich mitmache dann lässt
sie mich in ruhe wieder weiter vom pc hocken in wirklichkeit war das eigentlich falsch herum
gedacht weil wenn ich da gut abgeschnitten habe dann bedeutet dass ich bin nicht so dumm mich
zu bewerben sondern ich habe einfach nur keinen bock ja oder ich muss doch was mit holz machen
wo mir der typ von wo mir der typ vom arbeitsrahmen bei vom arbeitsamt zugeraten hat mach was mit
mach was it kannst vergessen mach was mit holz alle als für dummschwätzer alles wahnsinn
lucky das das verstehe jetzt nicht das war die zeit leute ich meine das hatte doch jeder von
euch schon mal in irgendeiner art und weise auch immer es sei denn ihr seid die geborenen
high performer kreiswelt mindset leute dass ihr einfach gerade wenn die schule vorbei ist ja gerade
gerade wenn wenn ihr mit der schule fertig seid und dann nicht direkt was habt dass ihr 24 7 vom
pc sitzen wollt und am liebsten wollt ihr diesen zustand auch möglichst lang aufrechterhalten weil
es gibt nichts besseres als als 24 7 vom pc zu sein zumindest dachte ich mir das damals als 24 7 vom
pc zu spiel zu sitzen in der zeit wo man halt noch gerne pc spiele spielt musstest du keinen
civilians machen doch doch habe ich gemacht habe ich später gemacht ich habe als erstes die die
bwl ausbildung gemacht aber wie gesagt ich habe ich nicht fertig gemacht danach habe ich civilians
gemacht ich habe civilians in einer behindertenwerkstatt gemacht und ich muss aus heutiger
sicht sagen also ich hatte mega berührungsängste ich glaube so kann man das nennen als ich wusste
überhaupt nicht wie ich mit den leuten umgehen soll wie es wahrscheinlich den meisten so geht
ja aber ich muss sagen im nachhinein ich hätte das im leben nicht hauptberuflich machen wollen
also so im sozialen sektor verdienst du nix und ist mega stressig und ein übelster scheiß job
aber trotzdem muss ich sagen es war nicht schlecht dass ich das gemacht habe ich glaube ich habe
sogar mal ein civilians video gemacht auf youtube oder ich habe noch nie ein video gemacht zum
zivilis waren könnte man tatsächlich mal machen habe ich ja ich kann mich da aber nicht mehr
daran erinnern anscheinend habe ich auch nicht den titel geschrieben ich bilde mir auch ein dass
ich das gemacht habe aber mal davon abgesehen die frage stellt sich ja heute gar nicht mehr
weil gibt es nicht mehr ja habe ich gemacht ich habe zivil ist in der behindertenwerkstatt
gemacht und aus heutiger sicht muss ich sagen es war wirklich gut dass ich das gemacht habe
ja da hat man einfach mal ein bisschen was anderes gesehen und mit mit mit den leuten
kommst du normalerweise so ja auch gar nicht in berührung ja genau aber das habe ich das habe
ich im stream erzählt oder das habe ich nicht im video erzählt mit dem typ der noch gucken wollte
ich habe dann als ich in meinem zivil ist ich hatte natürlich auch keinen bock großartig was
zu machen ja ihr kennt mich also ich bin mega faul was das angeht also was habe ich gemacht ich habe
zwei stunden von acht stunden am tag mich oder es ging was gelänger zweieinhalb stunden oder so
habe ich mich dort in den kiosk gehockt und habe sachen verkauft für die zwei mittagspausen und ich
habe während ich im kiosk gesessen habe ich habe da immer ein bisschen geld reingesteckt in die
kasse und habe übelst gefressen im kiosk die ganze zeit da habe ich bestimmt auch zehn kilo
zugenommen oder so in dem halben jahr in dem dreiviertel jahr zivildienst ich habe ich habe
ich habe nur das nur das ungesündeste zeugs gefressen fünf sneakers oder so in der mittagspause fünf
sneakers und drei leihen zwei maß das essen dort war auch mega abartig richtig eklig zwar das
ekligste essen was ich je irgendwo gesehen habe konnte es eigentlich nichts anderes machen wie im
kiosk die snacks fressen ich habe quasi den ganzen tag über kiosk snacks gefressen und ace saft mit
ganz viel zucker getrunken jaja so sah das früher aus bedtime richtig seit zehn minuten schon die
vorgesetzt auf was moment um was geht es hier jetzt gerade das größte wo ich mich bisher beworben habe
ist die telekom habe aber angst dass man da ausgenutzt wird aufgrund von anweisungen von
der höheren ebene weil da gibt es viele berichte aus meinen dass die vorgesetzten du machst deine
ausbildung die telekom ist ein ganz guter ausbildungsbetrieb du musst ja danach nicht
da bleiben wenn sie die auf den sack gehen aber ausbildung bei der telekom habe ich bisher
eigentlich ich will nicht sagen nur gutes aber fast nur gutes gehört ja also da würde ich mir
keine gedanken machen sowohl von den leuten die damals mit mir zusammen die ausbildung gemacht
haben und bei der telekom waren als auch hier im stream man hört eigentlich zu 99 prozent positives
von der telekom da würde ich mir keine gedanken machen dass die dass die kacke sind du willst
telekom ist ein großer laden das ist bei der ausbildung durchaus von vorteil da gibt es da
gibt es für alles regelungen und prozesse das ist nicht verkehrt da muss dir keine gedanken
machen hoffe lieber dass sie dich nehmen dann hast du einen gescheiten ausbildungsbetrieb ja
und du lernst ordentlich was ja ich glaube telekom ist wahrscheinlich echt eines der besten
ausbildungen machen kannst es gibt immer leute die plötzlich erzählen so nach dem motto das
ist ganz schlimm und da ist auch ganz schlimm da würde ich erst mal gar nichts drauf geben
die leute sind immer übelst am jammern mein opa hat mir zum beispiel immer erzählt es war so ein
standardspruch von dem der hat immer erzählt dass also dazu müsst ihr wissen dass ihr den
spruch versteht kordel heißt auf hessisch sowas wie sowas wie seil sowas wie schnur oder seil
kordel und mein opa hat immer zu mir gesagt zu jedem anlass wenn ich mal wenn ich mal wieder
quasi nicht gesagt habe euer opa du hast recht und und so ist das wenn ich ein bisschen mit
diskutieren wollte diskutieren muss mit meinem opa da hat mein opa immer zu mir gesagt ich dachte
das ist was was hessisches ja da hat mein opa immer zu mir gesagt so nach dem motto ja ja das
wird du bist nicht immer dann will durchsetzen können und zwar genau und er hat immer zu mir
gesagt du wirst noch mal später schwer kordel nachgeben müssen und das hat er immer zu allen
möglichen anlässen gesagt so nach dem motto wie ich noch ganz klein war hat er zu mir gesagt
warte mal ab wenn du dann in die schule kommst dann wirst du noch schwer kordel nachgeben müssen
also das kannst du nicht immer dann will durchsetzen so wollte mir damit sagen so bin ich in die schule
gekommen und war nicht so schlimm wie es mein opa immer erzählt hat so dann habe ich dann habe ich
mit meinem opa weiter diskutiert immer und habe ja opa das ist bis jetzt immer noch nicht eingetreten
warte mal bis du in die weiterführende schule kommst dann wirst du noch schwer kordel nachgeben
müssen auch nicht passiert warte mal bis du eine ausbildung machst dann wirst du schwer kordel
nachgeben müssen und und ausbilden und wenn du mal richtig arbeitest dann spätestens dann wirst du
mal schwer kordel nachgeben müssen ja aber es ist es ist verständlich hey bei meinem opa war das alles auch noch ein
bisschen anders mein opa kam aus einer zeit da hat ihn da wurden in der schule hat ihn der lehrer
noch auf die finger gehauen im stock und in der arbeit bei meinem opa war was der chef sagt gesetzt
und so ich ich gätte woher mein opa kommt und warum das so dinger immer erzählt hat aber naja
das ist das war für mich halt so richtiges typisches boomer gelabert damals und und wahrscheinlich
werde ich das gleiche später auch machen kann ich mir gut vorstellen das ist ja in jüngeren erzählen
erzähle so nach dem aber mir war das noch nicht so einfach und warte mal ab ist das und das aber
trotzdem eins muss man eins muss man wirklich sagen ich habe ich habe früher bei vielem gedacht
aber mein opa labert wieder ja aber manche sachen sehe ich mittlerweile schon nicht mehr so wie
früher sondern sondern vielleicht ein bisschen mehr wie wie es mein opa eigentlich früher schon
richtig gesagt hat aber manches dauert halt vielleicht ein bisschen gut jetzt gehe ich
aber echt ins bett leute wir sehen uns die tage vielleicht morgen bis dann macht's gut zu